although he's been a fixture in
Hollywood since his days on Saturday
Night Live in the 80s Eddie Murphy
hasn't really done all that much in the
last handful of years so where has he
been and what's even up to here is a
look at the real reason you don't hear
from Eddie Murphy anymore this was all
planned
although fans may be confused by
Murphy's recent absence from the big
screen the superstar comedian has
actually been laying the groundwork for
retirement for years planning to make
movies to lump 50 that's two years and
eight months then I'm going on then I'm
going back to the stage
since then Murphy has mostly lived up to
his word his last major star vehicle
Tower Heist hit theaters a few months
after his 50th birthday he since
appeared in only two other movies the
underwhelming a thousand words in 2012
and the very low profile in the mr.
Church which opened to mostly negative
reviews in 2016 meanwhile he did a bit
of stand-up for the first time in almost
three decades while accepting the Mark
Twain prize for American humor in 2015
you know they call it a prize it's an
award because usually when there's a
prize there's money involved
I thought I was gonna get some paper I
was like yo not interested in Hollywood
so why is Murphy basically retired
according to an interview with Rolling
Stone it's simple
he's just happy with his life I only
want to do what I really want to do
otherwise I'm content to sit here and
play my guitar all day I always tell
people now that I'm a semi-retired
gentleman of leisure and occasionally
I'll go do some work to break the
boredom up I'm chilling no stress sounds
pretty awesome from funny to flops
Murphy's big-screen career has always
been a bit of a roller coaster from
highs like Beverly Hills Cop to lows
like The Adventures of Pluto Nash which
remains one of Hollywood's biggest
failures still the last decade has been
especially unkind to Murphy in 2007 he
started Norbit for which he won three
Razzie Awards and followed that up with
a string of critical and box-office
bombs including meet Dave
imagine that and a thousand words to his
credit Murphy has been a bit more
reflective in recent years telling the
Washington Post that he was through
taking roles just for the money the
check movies are over for me
Oscar's snub Murphy made headlines in
November 2011 when he announced he would
no longer be hosting the 84th Annual
Academy Awards set to air the following
February his decision didn't exactly
come as a surprise it was announced a
day after the Brett Ratner the director
of Tower Heist had dropped out as the
telecast producer after making anti-gay
remarks and discussing his sex life on
Howard Stern still Murphy's decision to
quit the Oscars didn't sit well with
everyone especially among members of the
Academy one member until the Hollywood
Reporter this is like a big middle
finger to be Academy into the industry
while another added it was a career
mistake what the hell was he thinking
return to SNL Murphy was one of the many
famous faces who took part in Saturday
Night Live's 40th anniversary special in
February 2015 but despite his
high-profile appearance Murphy left many
fans underwhelmed when he gave what
amounted to a barely one-minute speech
what kept him from doing more
[Applause]
let's keep on let's have some more show
let's have a big round fluff everybody
according to the Washington Post SNL
wanted him to play Bill Cosby which
didn't sit well with Murphy at the time
given the Cosby was facing accusations
that he had sexually assaulted dozens of
women throughout his career I totally
understood why SNL wanted to do it it
was the biggest thing in the news at the
time I can see why they thought it would
be funny and the sketch that Norm
Macdonald wrote was hysterical but the
story is horrible there's nothing funny
about it if you get up there and you
crack jokes about him you're just
hurting people you're hurting him you're
hurting his accusers I was like hey I'm
coming back to SNL for the anniversary
I'm not turning my moment on the show
into this other thing ironically Murphy
wound up in personating Cosby while
accepting his Mark Twain award that
October some of the people who feel that
I should give back my dog eyes he
expanded his family Murphy's preference
for being a chill dad over a Hollywood
megastar was confirmed in May 2016 when
he and his girlfriend Paige butcher
welcomed their first child together is
he oona Murphy he clearly likes being a
dad he has eight other children with
four other women but while he's enjoying
new fatherhood once again there are
limits even for him don't change diapers
it's hard because I would be horrible at
it and it's not fair to the child
projects in the works although you may
not see much of Murphy these days that
doesn't necessarily mean he'll be gone
forever
in fact the actor has a number of
projects in development including a
role-playing Richard Pryor's father in
the new movie for Lee Daniels and the
long gestating fourth installment in the
Beverly Hills Cop franchise speaking to
Ellen DeGeneres about the latter project
in 2013
Murphy revealed that he and others were
still fine-tuning the script if you get
the script just write something that
will do but it'll be perfect cuz I don't
want to do anything else that sucks yeah
ever again
[Music]
that's a good goal that's a really good
goal I think most of us do extra good
well I almost sucked Nomo thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel
let's check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]